je suis Paul au RSA depuis deux ans je
travaille comme saisonnier dans la canne
à sucre et je souhaite trouver un emploi
stable j'informe mon conseiller Pôle
Emploi qu'un agriculteur me propose un
contrat de travail à temps partiel sur
son exploitation avec possibilité
d'évoluer à temps plein il me propose
r+, la location d'insertion et de retour
à l'emploi je suis donc un contrat avec
mon employeur puis un contrat r+, avec
le département avec cette aide durant
l'année où je suis à temps partiel mais
allocation sont maintenues et s'ajoutent
à mes revenus d'activité avec
l'accompagnement de mon conseiller
d'insertion mon objectif est d'obtenir
un contrat à temps plein r+, l'activité
en toute sécurité plus d'informations
sur www.department974.fr